christian was going to do his sweater
vest
i did my sweater
you have your special um what are those
long long johns all right yeah keep
yourself warm i mean we're all bundling
up folks
can you know something i don't
are you wearing uggs no no no she's got
the heater though yeah she does have the
heater you better get two heaters for
these next few days because yeah get
this true story my kid and her friends
came in this morning woke me up they're
like dad
it's cold outside i said thank you
captain obvious
it was chilly chilly it was chilly we
had the winds on top of that too that
thing's very chilly so can we repeat
again the answer is yes let's get it you
know the chili chilly night so christian
you can wear your sweater vest tomorrow
i give you permission i look outside
right now
we do have a light haze out there okay
but doesn't this look better than
yesterday where we couldn't even see the
mountains at all so yeah the air quality
as promised has improved however
the air quality advisory has been
canceled but we still have moderate
readings for smoke ozone dust and that
moderate range for air quality that's
going to change tomorrow this will turn
good tomorrow just have to deal with
this today no unhealthy readings though
for those of you with the sensitive
lungs so that's the good news 82 for sky
canyon centennial same for you what
wonderful numbers we're seeing outside
right now 83 in north las vegas right
now we should be in the 90s 80 for
whitney ranch we are not going to reach
90 at all today mountains edge at 78
roads ran same for you 83 in henderson
80 for anthem i just wish we had a
sunroof here guys we needed to open up
right
right maybe next year 76 for indian
springs 82 for a mesquite 86 for
laughlin get out there and enjoy that
weather should be a nice evening we had
clouds this morning we had haze this
morning but notice that low just
pivoting its way towards the east
bringing that up the clouds along with
it some showers still right around i-40
around sedona there too but kingman's
clearing up too so we'll have clear
skies for tonight clear skies and camera
winds are going to allow the
temperatures to drop even more that's
why tomorrow's morning will be chillier
than we saw this morning futurecast does
show however this low will start to form
off the coast of california late weekend
and look at this could spin
shower chances our way on tuesday right
now that's a big could a big if but then
this moves its way out of there by
wednesday and then the clouds will clear
out as well so here's the big story your
overnight lows will be below normal
we're talking the low 60s for thursday
and friday morning okay we haven't seen
that since late may and then we're going
to see the numbers start to go up this
is right near normal by monday and then
those numbers will drop again by midweek
so overnight low 61 degrees clear and
cool now some of you may find it chilly
for tomorrow morning a hoodie may be
needed a sweater vest for christian 84
degrees for tomorrow cooler than normal
gusts up to 25 all right so it'll be a
little breezy for your thursday so
here's your eight day set up eight on
the eights cool mornings for thursday
and friday remember the aces play
tomorrow the night's on friday and take
a look at next week low 90s and then
right back to the high 80s again with
that slight shower chance that we'll be
watching on tuesday
bundle up that's your most accurate
forecast here on 8 news now